[Music]
[Applause]
let's uh bring in albert breer i got a
lot of questions i don't know if albert
now albert's really good but i don't
know if he's got answers to this the
senior nfl reporter and uh lead content
strategist for the monday morning
quarterback
let me start with deshaun watson
where do we stand with deshaun watson
given that the texans are now on their
backup quarterback davis mills if mills
had gotten hurt albert who comes in to
play quarterback for the texans
well you know what what's interesting um
dan is that you know i talked to david
cully about this last week and you know
he basically said that like he's in a
good place with deshawn and they sort of
have an understanding on the way things
are going to go going forward and
every indication that you get now he
didn't give me specifics on what their
agreement is
but you know it does certainly seem like
the idea is that he's basically not
going to be playing this year and he'll
be in the building but
he's not going to be around the team
very much and he's not going to be part
of the day-to-day process of getting
ready to play
and so like i don't even know if he'd be
ready to play on thursday so my guess
would be
um you know i haven't looked at their
practice squad but my guess would be
either they pull somebody up from the
practice squad or they get somebody off
the street to come in
and again like you know i think that as
awkward as this is dan
um you know i think for both sides it's
just about preserving value at this time
at this point you know where
um you know i mean the texans want to
preserve deshaun watson's trade value
that's the reason he's still on the team
and i think for for watson it's you know
and i it's a matter of sort of
protecting yourself in this situation
okay but there's an agreement it feels
like without
yeah so the nfl doesn't want him on the
field i'm guessing the texans want to
preserve his right uh you know or his
trade rights and then watson probably
like you want to pay me 10 million
dollars to not play then great so it's
right is that what's going on here like
it's like i mean
here yeah so so i mean like really if
you want the crux of why he's still on
the roster and they're in this situation
to begin with it's because nick casario
is not taking less he's not going to
take 50 cents on the dollar
and like until somebody steps up and
offers the texans what they would have
been able to get
in january or february or march i don't
think they're moving them and you know i
think it's
i mean look nick knows this is his
herschel walker right like and when it
comes to building the franchise out this
is the most valuable piece of capital
i'm not you know like i hate to refer to
a player that way but that's what it is
like in this situation it's the most
valuable piece of capital that he has in
the building um to to build the roster
back up and
even if he were to trade him now
like when's he using those picks
not till april anyway right
so
like why would you take less now when
there could be clarity three four five
months down the line and you get a whole
lot more for them especially when you
know you're in a year when you're
rebuilding to begin with
so
yeah i think once
desean and the and and kelly
um came to kind of a comfort level with
where they are you know as again as
awkward as this has been for the last
six months um you know i think that
there's sort of an agreement there that
the texans really just aren't going to
move them right now and until somebody
whether it's the dolphins the panthers
the broncos the eagles any of the teams
that we've talked about steps up and
makes the sort of offer form that they
would have been able to get
before the 22 lawsuits were filed he's
not going to be moved
and you know i know that's not
preferable for for deshaun right now but
um you know i do think that at the very
least um you know where this was really
sideways two or three months ago
i i think david collie's done a nice job
of at least managing it where it's not
affecting his team on a day-to-day basis
can you explain the cowboys clock
management yesterday in l.a
um yeah it's interesting i talked to
greg zurline zeroline after the game and
um
you know i asked him i said
like did you feel comfortable kicking
from 56 he said like yeah i'll do what
the coaches ask me to he said well did
you talk to mike mccarthy or john fossil
their special teams coach um either
before the game at the half like when
when you guys got the ball back
about like how far you were good from
and he said no he said i just i go out
there and the way that we've already
done it we've always done it the special
teams coach was with him with the rams
for a lot of years
he said like they have confidence in me
they know how far i'm good from and and
we're good
and so like that was the funny thing
about it was like zeroline literally
told me he was literally standing there
a lot like as the clock was ticking down
30 20 10.
like literally was like okay i guess i'm
going out there now you know and so it
was a weird circumstance but i do know
like the fact that you know he nailed a
48 yarder the week before i'm a big one
again in tampa
um you know down the stretch of that
game sort of played in the decision
making and obviously fossil having all
that background with sirloin did too so
i just thought it was funny that you
know because i
you see some teams like all the
belichick teams right it's like before
the game it's like a science figuring
out how far your kicker's good from
and mccarthy and fossil just sort of let
this ride and um you know i in in a
funny sort of way zeroline told me kind
of instilled some confidence in him that
he knew that they had that sort of
confidence i mean his ability to get the
job done well also the game was tied
yeah and that's the other thing yep
worst case scenarios you know you go
into overtime
uh trey lance did not play
was that by design
i think it's a close game um you know
and i think more competitive than some
people thought it would be i also think
that the opponent's always going to play
into this stan and
um
part of it with the eagles there's not a
lot of you know there's not like really
a book written on that coaching staff
right now
and so not only do you have a new head
coach and nick siriana you got a new
defensive coordinator jonathan gannon
who'd only coached one game and he's got
one of the best defensive lines in
football it's aging a little bit and i
know brandon graham got hurt in game
yesterday but
i mean that's still one of the best
defensive lines in football and so
you know i think so much of getting
trey lance in there in spots is about
making him comfortable right and like
let's slowly ramp him up it's actually
what the niners did with colin
kaepernick all those years ago playing
behind alex smith
and so you know if you think that it's a
disadvantageous situation for the young
guy you're not going to put them out
there
and i think it's also a sign
and i know people don't believe the
niners when they say this but i think
it's a sign that they do have confidence
one healthy jimmy garoppolo can get the
job done for him
and um you know i know jimmy feels more
comfortable in kyle's offense than he
ever has before and he feels like he's
playing his best ball and so yesterday
was just about winning that game and um
you know like that's what kyle's
maintained each one of these things is
going to be about is it's just winning
that game and they didn't need trade to
win the game yesterday and they they
felt like maybe the the spot wasn't a
great one for a young guy to get thrown
out in we're talking albert breer senior
nfl reporter for the monday morning
quarterback were the jets irresponsible
yesterday with zach wilson
you know
i have a hard time with this one because
like i look at
listen to this number dan all right
um and this is just kind of comparing
and contrasting the two situations
mac jones
had um mac jones
faced i think it was 12 third downs
yesterday right 16 the week before okay
that's 28 for the season so far only
four of those third downs have been
third and ten or longer think about that
only four through two games has he been
in third and ten or longer
so
what i saw on one side was the patriots
manage like very carefully managing
their quarterback and trying to build
confidence in them and saying you got a
good team around you we've got a good
running back behind you we've got a good
defense on the other side i mean max
still hasn't played from further down
than a single possession
and
it's i mean
they're making it easier on him whereas
the jets
like i it just feels like they're
they're in this spot now where it's like
all right kid go win the game for us you
know what i mean like and part of it's
the place the roster's in and everything
else but so much of that goes into how a
young quarterback develops you know
and so like
i know you're saying you're asking
should they should they have yanked him
right like should they have pulled him
out of the game and maybe they should
have because maybe it wasn't good for
him from a confidence standpoint to keep
going out there and and and throwing it
up the way that he did
um you know but i think a lot of it sort
of speaks to you know maybe a first-year
coaching staff
i think they have to learn how to manage
the game a little bit differently and i
think they have to learn how to protect
their young quarterback and keep them
out of those situations where he feels
like he's got to go win it and um you
know i think if he is in those sorts of
spots enough he could develop bad habits
so i think they have to be careful with
it
the taunting rules are interesting
interesting or awful
well they're awful
yeah but
there's an etiquette to taunting
you have to kind of taunt away from the
guy you just beat basically right
it feels like i i hate
rules that are open to interpretation
it just gets into that gray area where
we as fans go wait what are you what
happened like yeah or what why'd you
call that
was it was it jared cook the one who i
think jared cook went up and did the
stirring thing right like was he the one
like and i think that that was that was
the touchdown that got overturned right
because of the illegal shift at the end
of the chargers cowboys game
and i was watching that and jared cook's
been in the league for 10 years he's a
pro it's not like some young guy who
didn't know how to act you know what i
mean like and he got up
bounced to his feet and gestured that
really quickly and it obviously didn't
wind up having an effect on the game
because the illegal shift sort of
superseded the um the taunting foul but
i'm sitting there thinking to myself
like
like i don't know that he knew the other
guy was going to be standing right there
when he got up and did that it was just
a reaction of emotion and wasn't that
what like we were trying to green light
like a year or two ago when they changed
the celebration rules right so if you're
a player right now like how confusing is
that you have to like before you get up
and celebrate you have to look around
and make sure somebody's not there
and then like and then you think about
it and it's like how much judgment goes
into this well okay like how come that's
okay
but
or that's not okay but lamar jackson
somersaulting into the end zone and i
think lamar was fantastic last night and
the the best story of week two probably
but like how is it okay that he's
somersaulting into the end zone and
jared cook's like just bouncing to his
feet and doing a small little
celebration isn't you know
i just like
i just think that this is like they're
opening pandora's box on this one
and if you're a player it'd be so easy
to be confused by this because a year
ago they were telling you go nuts do
whatever you want we want you to play on
emotion we want you to be happy when you
score we want you to be
you know pumped and celebrate with your
teammates when you make a big play and
now they're turning around and say oh
yeah but like we're going to draw these
imaginary lines around everything that
you're allowed to do
what's different about kyler murray this
year as opposed to last year
you know i had a really interesting
conversation with him during training
camp dan and
um
he basically said flat out to me
i have never lost so much in my life as
i did the first two years of my career
and it's interesting because you think
about him in high school he never lost a
high school start won three straight big
school state championships in texas
right
then he was a spot starter at a m and i
think he might have lost a game or two
his freshman year but he goes to
oklahoma and he wins the heisman and i
think they lost one game that year so
here's a guy in like i mean seven years
of football started maybe one game that
he lost
and so um you know like just that
discussion i had with him was really
interesting in that it really aided him
and i think you know having talked to
cliff about it yesterday you know cliff
made it sound like he really took it to
heart like he took it personally like
this isn't what's about this isn't about
what's around me this is about me like
i'm the quarterback and those losses go
on my record
and so this offseason he took more
ownership of the offense and
you know so much of it i think you know
and cliff was looking to make the team
to to to build some maturity into the
team and bring in guys like aj green and
jj watt and rodney hudson
and like while all that was going on
like cliff really noticed kyler was sort
of taking ownership of the entire thing
and so that meant you know having his
teammates at texas to throw in in april
and may and you know having another
throwing session in arizona for the guys
who couldn't make it there
and um you know i think what you've
noticed and what you see now is a guy
who's more comfortable out there playing
within cliff's offense and understanding
what he can and can't do in the nfl
but also a guy who was so competitive
and had
i think
lost
who who
wasn't happy with the results of his
first couple of years in the league
and
really kind of took responsibility for
losing in arizona even if he wasn't
personally responsible for all of it
great to catch up with you as always uh
thanks for joining us albert great
thanks dan have a good one that's albert
breer you can read the monday morning
quarterback it's online senior nfl
reporter lead content strategist